aktuelle zahlen deutschland hat es 2016
zum zweiten mal in folge geschafft beim
co2 ausstoß drauf zu legen also wir
haben nicht nur nichts reduziert wir
haben plus gemacht mehr ja da passt es
doch wunderbar dass die groko ihr super
wichtiges klimaziel für 2020 also 40
prozent weniger co2 im vergleich zu 1990
komplett aufgibt ja weil
bei mancher ähnlich mehr schafft dann
müsste man jetzt regelrecht alte
kohlekraftwerke abschalten und wo ist
der schalter kommen hier kurz
zurückgespult in den heißen wahlkampf
herbst 2017 reinhören und genießen ich
sage wir werden wege finden wie wir bis
2020 unter 40 prozent ziel einhalten das
verspreche ich ihnen wunderbar wunderbar
ja bei sowas erwischt man sie nur ganz
selten kann ich den hinteren teil noch
einmal hören
das verspreche ich ihnen die musik ja
habe ich als klingelton natürlich
natürlich steht im gros sondierungs
papier nicht etwa wir geben auf nein
nein da heißt es nur die handlungs lücke
zur erreichung des klimaziels weiteren
20 wollen wir so schnell wie möglich
schließen ist viel schöner oder eine
handlungs lücke weil keiner gehandelt
hat